your husband said the other day that you  wanted him to retire he said that not me  you know the thing is and that he was  gonna play as long as he felt as good as  he does man are you trying to get him to  retire you know I just have to say as a  wife I'm a little bit you know it's as  you know it's not the most like let's  say an aggressive sport right football  like he had a concussion last year I  mean he has concussions pretty much I  mean we don't talk about but he does  have concussions and he's I don't really  think it's a healthy thing for your body  to go to like a you know to that kind of  aggression like all the time that could  not be healthy for you right and I'm  planning on having him be healthy and do  a lot of fun things when we're like 100  I hope